l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuto questo
video sono falliti entrati su blair
witch non sapremo mai se chiami ski
operati da tap può morire anche
protagonista ma il cane
no quindi speriamo seguitelo con me
buona visione
quindi ragazzi abbiamo abbandonato per
finta al mio cane però camp a a sinistra
som il sarebbe segheria quando doveva
pietro cosa c'è
hai trovato la foto di pietro ben grazie
grazie e cosa c'è scritto come si
prendono gli oggetti fa niente non fa
niente va beh mi fido vado nella
segheria a destra ragazzo vado vado a
vado a sinistra vado a sinistra scatta
allora c'è un tunnel
il che non so cosa dire però seguiamo
bullet stami dietro per corti bravo
esatto perché se non ho paura che già
prima ti hanno abbandonato per finta 15
ho paura che ti faccio a staccare da me
voglio assolutamente che il mio cane mi
rimanga per tutto il gioco quindi vi
ammazzo sono toccate dove stiamo andando
esattamente al campeggio o ha forse
posso utilizzarlo per passare nel punto
di prima possibile
se lo spingo ed acqua forse riesco a
passare in mezzo a quelli ai mostri di
prima può essere prova tesoro di qua
salita li bravo non cadere giù e anche
poi un casino
allora
l'uomo da fare ma ti spiega come guido
io tranquilli piega come vida sta roba
che avvia il freno a mano
tanto lo so vi al freno a mano
tutto al massimo start stop entrata ma
stiamo andando
ma questo cosa serve ai la luce la luce
è ok va bene mi piace sta parte non devo
fare niente non stare perdere e se
invece lasciato andare il cane reboot
giu però non lo farò più e meglio
beh bene quindi non faccio nulla posso
solo tirare il freno a mano per adesso
godiamoci viaggetto ragazzi di sopra
comunque non c'era tutto sto casino
prima aspetto questa ragazza che riesca
a frenare frena frenati a bra ci siamo
schiacciati quindi fa niente si è
schiantato scusami ma non è la prima
c'era un'altra strada ma cosa è successo
pepsi ma prima c'era un'altra strada
completamente mamma mia quanto al suo
pezzo bene a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti
dentro il villaggio dei morti
niente da fare ma è questa la segheria
no sì ci sono degli alberi per punta c'è
o non c'è un cassetto che grazie bravo
ha fatto bene a bajardo guarise a ti fa
vedere come si accende la macchina dai
ragazzi ora prepara a scendere sta roba
perché teoricamente semi riguardo il
filmato dovrei riuscire a dargli e vago
se tutto giusto quindi qua prima che ci
avete dato fuoco non so come sta già
funzionando
quindi se io scendo bravo bellissima
comunque ragazzi sarebbe veramente fine
cioè non so non sei quanti giochi hanno
fatto una roba del genere ma sta roba è
un'idea incredibile comunque funziona
valvola ma manca un pezzo
devo trovare il pezzo della valvola cane
trova a pezzo di valvola ama tutto sto
casino perché devo cambiare la
postazione al binario teoricamente tutto
sto casino serve per levare il tronco di
qualche bello legato il problema è che
come diavolo trovo del manca un pezzo
idricamente dovrei prendere il carrello
e andare a cercare questo pezzo forse
cioè almeno tre di queste ok quindi va
sinistra la sinistra la sinistra sembra
proprio lui devo andare a cercare orco
demonio aspetta che ho visto robe
addizionali ho visto una cosa lì cosa
che c'era da andare a cercare pezzo
mancanti tutto questo però il carrello
st continua ad andare avanti quindi qua
c'è un pezzo mancante di valvola no urko
demonio porco a verifichi un'altra
segheria non è proprio il massimo
cercare di andare dentro qua dentro non
ci dovrei andare teoricamente prova
bendia voci tanto stupido
ok non questo da nessuna parte sono qui
dentro quindi teoricamente sono san
salvo
salvo il suo salvatore io sono salvo ma
ho visto dove che se non vedo neanche il
mio cane come faccio vedere lui
eccolo eccolo bravissimo perfetto da mi
davi a me porto fuori pato fuori potro
vari può trovare bravo il mio cognome
tino bello sto specchio no è un
manometro e quindi il pezzo che mancava
la roba quindi adesso posso andar lì e
togliere teoricamente però dovrei
riprendere il carrello e fastidio
ho trovato di tutto questo è il pezzo
che mi mancava ma siamo ritorno ma è un
cerchio diavolo ma io non avevo capito
quindi a posto fermati frena preferenze
frena bravo è un certo non avevo capito
come adesso cambia strada vai dritto
band per sul tronco che tanto le solo
leviamo farà teoricamente vengo qua
molto il pezzo e ci siamo tutto esatto
non so quanto devo andare
l'ho girato un po non ho capito si sta
levando il tronco eccolo lì non so
neanche come ho fatto proprio bene le
righe 6 ori però per fare sta roba tra
ce l'abbiamo fatta
salta sul carrello e via verso nuovi
orizzonti ragazzi sempre che adesso non
arrivi satana come sempre a romperci un
po le balle ma quello sempre ragazzi
quindi tutta dritta o perfetto che bello
ragazzi è proprio una bella sensazione
mi sento un capostazione fortissimo ciao
ciao
c'è il trenino nel kringe va bè ragazzi
stiamo andando abbastanza bene direi
perché ancora non sono morto una volta
chi è incredibile non gioco così i cieli
sembra aver visto qualcosa però ci
permetterà mi sa che qui stiamo tornando
da ecco il tutto sto casino per poter
passare di qua e tanto non ci sono
neanche i binari quelli che ci sto passa
a sono sotto le foglie e minareto così
sta roba successo
no no no no no no no sorriso maledizione
ci manca solo questo ragazzi si ferma
siamo nella cassetta implodendo raga
siamo morti morte in diretta
bella tutti ragazzi nove ragazzi siamo
fra schiattando io lo dico sia scattando
se sta roba si ferma io sono morto
definitivamente però tira avanti provaci
c'è il ponte potrebbe anche crollare
volendo ci manca solo quello dai
fratello dai dai dai tanto qua non ci
possono raggiungere psicosi siamo già
salvi perché teoricamente non ci
raggiungono la bassa che il ponte non
crolla
io l'ho detto ragazzi
[Musica]
non è crollato ma veramente ora che non
è crollato sto male allora si è crollato
ma noi siamo passati mamma mia che culo
che culo dov'è il mio cane o madonna
sotto sotto ci siamo signori non mi
ricordo neanche di questo ci sta facendo
qua ragazze alla segheria però ci siamo
sbaglio c'è qualcuno alla finestra salve
mi scusi eh lui è il tizio quello che ha
ucciso e lui erano ragazzi era tipo che
ha ucciso il
lo sceriffo non ti fa ammazzare
dell'uomo cattivo gruppo madonna come lo
voglio io sto cane ragazze bellissimo
giorno
red mau a prima volta i scusi signor
jason sono io a ecco vedi che c'era una
scala esterna
raga
c'è una nursery buongiorno le manca un
piede lo sa questo non di là dove lo
vedo la piastrina cosa che dice ok
cheese files tester
o a posso muovermi non è un ricordo vai
mai attivato allora che schifo beh
simpatico secondo me fa male sta roba
devo guardare per forza va bene ragazzi
non guardate il video come lo guardo
solo io li puntava una pistola gli ha
sparato è definito segato non nel modo
in cui pensate voi mani in questo ok
magari è meglio se si disattiva questo
cose che dite
va bene usciamo cioè come ho fatto a far
fare ad attivare questa cosa qui usciamo
si apre la porta bene
sì perché se attivo il coso teoricamente
mi si attiva tutta la segheria quindi va
bene bullet non giocare con cui il
cristiano li vieni qua con le bollette e
mi scusi mi scusi il cane mio il cane il
cane mio se proprio vogliamo dammi il
basto il cusi barber
ho visto guarigione
così visto il family friendly si che
l'ho visto ma volete vedere che questo
volete vedere ragazzi questo è il
bambino scomparso che ha cresciuto nella
foresta e dei tipo cambiato il tempo non
lo so sto sparando a zero sta strozzando
la manovra ragazzino moria ok perfetto
non è non è lui sembra un po non è
perché voglio ritornare sempre su auto
ma quanto sembra il tipo di auto aste
quello di auto 2 l'inizio bruttissimo il
tipo che era fortissimo non riuscivo a
menarlo mai uguale c'è veramente super
simile quindi addio mio ragazzo sono
scegliero mamma ma perché giro
incredibile sto facendo
dov'è che stiamo andando ad un casino ci
sei a posto compare se starnuto o
macchina c'è un buco ma che è successo
saprai non c'e la roba che non potete
sbagliare
no guardi c'è o mio dio non levare non
le varie fazzoletto non avevamo fatto
nel suo cuore se n'è andato il pari
ah meno male meno male meno male meno
male che differivano torna mestiere
aiuto non sparare a qualcuno oa me
stesso o al cane cosa devo fare
ma non gli sparerò mai mai non ammazzerò
bullet con un bullo smettila si stai
zitto smettila incassato anche lui
adesso
adesso però no io non la guarda se la
gente stupida la gente stupida non ha il
cervello questo l'ha trovato sul suo ali
express ma cristo ma mai non può solo io
non so lo giuro su dio io non ce la
posso periodo
non ho le forze ragazzi ma ti rendi
conto della demenza di cai nel cervello
ce l'hai cane cane cane due bulletti due
figli ma sta succedendo ragazzi dai vi
prego che se mischiate al cane muoio
amici fammi vedere
fammi sander e l'ascom esigendo i quali
qua è successo e kaman porco demonio
corpo dopo la gente stupida avevo
nell'inter non è certo cosa è successo è
successo al cane chi me la sto tirando
lo so già però è che dopo però che vi
sia piaciuto un commento un bel laiche
iscrivete del canale schiacciate la
campanellina e come sempre ci riuniamo
ad un prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]